françois fillon et alain houpert côte à
côte dans les rues de dijon
nous sommes en 2014 l'ancien premier
ministre vient soutenir le candidat à la
mairie
une scène qui n'est pas prêt de se
reproduire hier le sénateur de côte-d'or
est le premier parlementaire a emboîté
le pas de georges fenech et a lâché le
candidat à la présidentielle je pense
que notre candidat doit arrêter
on parle beaucoup de plan b mais je
pense que le plan b c'est pas un bon
symbole c'est un plan de repêchage il
faut une élection qui soit noble
il faut un candidat de droite qui soit
fort notre candidat est affaibli à la
houppe rad soutenu nicolas sarkozy lors
de la primaire valérie grande et elle
avait préféré françois fillon sur
twitter elle s'insurge françois fillon a
été choisi par près de 3 millions de
français des officines veulent
l'empêcher d'être candidat
avec la diffusion annoncée ce soir sur
france 2 d'une interview de pénélope
fillon qui déclarait en 2007 n'avoir
jamais été l'assistante de son mari les
parlementaires tenter de trouver un plan
b pour voir présenter la droite à la
présidentielle pourrait devenir plus
nombreuses